hi Pete I can how are you doing I'm good
how are you write it NASA yep space the
final frontier
okay so let me start by saying I was 19
years old in 1969 when when we walked on
the moon and at the time I thought that
was just like the biggest boondoggle
waste of time money and everything else
that I could possibly imagine so well
obviously feel differently I was 19 also
in 19 there's sort of three things we do
in NASA and I think people tend to
forget them either the first one and I'm
a scientist is science and we're finding
out the secrets of the universe in the
last couple decades we revolutionized
physics and each new discovery shows we
know less about the universe than we did
before it's job security for physicists
that's good but it culminated really in
a few years ago and in a Nobel Prize for
a NASA civil servant so it's quite an
honor for for a fellow civil servant the
next decade or two I think they're the
decade of biology and we are on the
verge I believe of finding out where
else in the universe life exists does it
exist elsewhere are we the only life and
that's a pretty significant scientific
thing second and and and this is
probably more important to other people
we do a lot of things to help life on
earth aviation is the first day in NASA
we are confronted with a crisis and as
everyone knows and most everyone knows
in the climate change and one of the
things we have to do is build green
airplanes things that enable us to
continue to bring the world closer
together at the same time without
spewing more carbon in the atmosphere
the other thing is really understanding
climate change and itself I'm
increasingly intrigued and terrorized
frankly that we study mass extinctions
on the earth and there were six major
ones
the last big one was which did away with
the dinosaurs or so we think
was caused by an asteroid but the
previous five one seemed to be tied up
with climate change and changing the
biology of the ocean the last thing we
do and what it gets all the attention is
what Apollo was all about was we are in
the verge of extending humanity into the
solar system into the cosmos and as a
space guy that's to me maybe the most
exciting sometime in the next half
century we will leave this world forever
and at that point humanity intelligence
life art is going to go in an
unbelievable set of direction so I think
you know my answer is we do space
because we're human and you know more
than the individual important sub parts
which are still important what do you
mean in the next half-century we're
gonna leave this earth forever is that
what you say yes I the the primary
objective of NASA now is is to begin the
settlement of the solar system now
whether that's on the Moon or Mars or
asteroids but that is the objective is
to develop the technology and the
ability to place a permanent I won't
even say human let's say a settlement of
something on another world now there's a
lot of philosophical arguments both ways
but that's going to happen whether it
happens by governments whether it
happens by private individuals or
consortium no but I'm convinced by the
middle of the century there will be a
human settlement probably on Mars and at
that point it goes in all sorts of
wonderful directions well without
getting into current politics or getting
at the current politics so it seems like
NASA as an agency that's underseater as
maybe not so well thought of as it was
back in the 60s and the 70s is that true
and how is the agency responding to that
well I think that's yes you know I mean
in the 60s we were part of the Cold War
part of the security and and that's
where people's attention now now we have
a lot of other problems and so I think
that we're less central to most people's
thinking at the
same time though you know the the NASA
is probably the only u.s. brand that's
still pretty good you know you go to
Africa and other places you see kids
wearing NASA t-shirts you don't see him
wearing IRS t-shirts so you know I think
it's a every place I go you know I used
to be in the Air Force and you know if
you're told somebody on a flight you're
in the Air Force they you know
baby-killer but you know I have a NASA
button and and everywhere people talk
about I was just in Saudi Arabia and the
Saudis have a real challenge is some
time that all money runs out they have
to become in their opinion a
knowledge-based economy before that
happens they want to tie with NASA they
want to use our logo and they've had a
Saudi astronaut and it's it's an
inspiration to everybody to you know we
can be part of this this particular
direction of the future of humanity is
there is there a I mean I have to
confess despite my first statement there
is something sort of romantic and
fabulous about space exploration and
pushing those frontiers and I think for
artists as well it's this pushing into
the unknown right it's like going in
places where you're not comfortable and
you don't know what's going to happen
and and even it's a little dangerous
like in this case where maybe physically
dangerous and the artists are certainly
intellectually emotionally and sometimes
physically dangerous in the work that
they do so in that sense I think it's it
it's a place where science and art
actually come together pretty well very
much so I mean it's you know I think the
inspiration for people to do to beyond
the frontiers is the same as whether
it's art or science it is a quest to
better understand the university live in
it and one of the questions I guess to
ask you is you know when and I'll say
when we form new cultures elsewhere what
art should we take with us I mean
sending a bunch of engineers to Mars is
probably not the best way to start we
should probably take some artists or art
or thinking because it I mean what is
your thoughts on that
you know that's an interesting question
I guess I'm I'm kind of intrigued by
this idea of what would be the if I if I
could pigs they're the this is like a
science fiction thing right I could pick
the people that would be in that
settlement what's the composition of
people and and of course there's a
certain level of well we need people can
sustain this settlement right so we need
the mechanics and we need the people who
can and the engineers and the people who
can sustain this but if that's as far as
we want to go then that's all we need
but if we want people who are going to
who are going to create and take that
next step further then I would say yes
that's when we need artists and and
thinkers and idea people the Pachuca put
the part that I'm kind of curious about
is that that and particularly now I
think that that those thinkers are the
most scary to most people and in most
institutions at this moment in time so
there's I think there's as unconscious
at least effort to put a lid on all of
this crazy dangerous thinking and let's
and I'm not just wondering if you have
that same that same experience in terms
of I'm thinking maybe that's why NASA is
having sort of a struggle now right
because we don't want all of that crazy
thinking it's scaring us a little bit
well it's interesting you I just got
back from a two-butted a kumbaya session
I guess you'd call it with it with the
NASA leadership to try to figure out and
and and I have to confess to being the
radical I I represent that you know
there's 10 NASA centers and we're in the
Silicon Valley so and and in the San
Francisco Bay Area so we're regarded is
not being exactly typical government
employees and I'm proud of that but I
think that that any constructive effort
and it's hard to be constructive and
creative and in the government
bureaucracy must have that mix and
and when you look at scientific
endeavors that have been done in the
past that have succeeded they tend to
have that spirit of you know radicalism
and and you know sort of giving the
system a finger every sip now right and
so I think that that's going to be
essential it one of the problems that
NASA has had in the last few years is we
became a bit of a of a bureaucratic you
know sort of just another day at work
kind of thing and I and I think that the
what we need to do is if we're going to
do great things in NASA we're gonna do
great things in the government we're
gonna do great things in private sectors
or universities you have to have that
spark and it that's why I'm really
concerned that if we do settle another
world and when we do that we take along
the people with us that are going to to
think I mean it's a over word overused
term outside the box right you know I
mean in my view there shouldn't even be
a box but but i but i think that that's
a struggle yeah that's what I was
getting I completely agree I think that
there's there's a there's one of the
reasons many of us are finding it so
difficult in this particular moment in
time is because there is this kind of
overwhelming desire to to not have that
expansive thinking right you know you
schools teach to the test there's a
prescribed thing that you're supposed to
know once you know that then your
so-called educated and that's pushed out
never mind what Melissa was saying about
science education art education it's
also out the window because that's not
deemed necessary once you get to it you
know it doesn't fit inside this box and
yet that's where the creative thinkers
and the creative ideas are coming from
that will propel us into the future that
to my mind is one of the most exciting
things about the idea is that sometime
in some of our lifetimes there will be
alternative places there'll be
alternative societies that are really
separate you know the the discussion
here previously about the Polynesian
explorers that
in fact there was a museum and the Big
Island Hawaii that our planetarium that
combines the the traditional exploration
with new exploration in it and it's very
interesting that cultures I mean we
always use the Europeans you know coming
to the new world but I think it's more
interesting to look at some of these
other things that into Polynesians going
to other places that that what did they
bring with them and I think that that
allowed a flowering of creativity if
there is an alternative and
unfortunately as the world becomes
closer together there isn't an
alternative so we may represent that one
place that the fifty or hundred years
from now if you want to go someplace
that you're not constrained by the
society it might not be on this planet
so you know you'd mentioned earlier that
you know the NASA and its origins being
part of the Cold War and certainly that
was my experience of it too but I'm just
curious then given what you just said if
there's a sensibility around a more
transnational approach to spit it's
always been such a like space race right
between the US and Russia is that dead
is that is there something happening
that it's not quite dead but it it's
getting data and should be dead and in
my opinion it's sort of interesting that
a I was as I said I was in Saudi Arabia
a few weeks ago and it was commemorating
the flight of the first Saudi astronaut
who happened to be the nephew of the
king so selections are a little
different in other countries and Prince
I go many ways right but at any rate he
he told the story that when they were in
the Space Shuttle and there was also a
French astronaut and he said the first
day they were all pointing to the to the
country they were from they fly over say
that's you know where I was born he said
the next day they were pointing to the
continent and he said by the third or
fourth day it was just there all humans
from this planet and I think maybe the
most important philosophical thing that
that happened in the Space Age was those
iconic pictures of the moon
you know with the earth rising over it
you look at this little fragile ball and
we're all living on that spaceship and I
think that that changed forever that
concept so that's the spirit that really
is is is going to bring us together and
so in some sense it you know space
represents that the one place that you
know you don't see any boundaries from
space well certainly that's interesting
from an artistic point of view I think a
lot of artists have done projects with
those photographs or photographs like
those there's a sense of awe that's
inspired by seeing the Earth from space
that I think it inspires artists to do
interesting projects around that as well
have you ever been in space no no I
probably I was on a finalist list to be
an astronaut once but the you know it's
I would still love to do it in fact we
might get a chance to do it you know
there are now commercial suborbital
flights that are almost within the reach
of a government employee but so I think
in the next decade there will be
opportunities I mean if I you know
happen to have a senior job at my
next-door neighbor Google I might have
enough money if I own orbit but it is
that's an interesting question is that
we are seeing the private sector get
into space and there'll be private
opportunities for people to fly so you
know I'm at the age and the physical
condition that's the only way I'll
probably get in space I pay somebody
yeah yeah okay I'm gonna go a completely
weird direction here and ask you about
extraterrestrials I believe in such
things
extraterrestrial life yes that's a very
interesting question and there's a
concept called the Fermi paradox mm-hm
and you know the that says if you if we
expect that there's nothing particularly
unusual about us you know we're on a
middle-aged star and you know there's a
lot of older ones and younger ones and
kind of a nondescript part of the galaxy
you know nondescript galaxies that if
life is everywhere there should have
been civilizations that are eons ahead
of us but Jill tarter was talked earlier
that as we look into space we don't see
anything and you know we haven't looked
very far but
if life is everywhere how come we don't
see it now I know a lot of people that
think they have seen it I know people
think they've had rides in spaceships
most of them tend be a little weird and
they were worried before they had the
ride in the spaceship but I for one
don't see any evidence of of intelligent
life elsewhere begs the question of
whether it's here of course but but I do
see evidence we're seeing tantalizing
evidence of microbial life on Mars and
other places and we are on the verge of
finding that life but one of the
possibilities and this is one that the
number of folks have involved and along
now discussed is that that life or
intelligence gets to a crisis where the
in fact it's called a singularity where
we see accelerating technology
particularly information biology in fact
we're within probably a few decades of
what some believe true artificial
intelligence that what happens to life
is they become something else in fact
maybe they leave the universe or they're
not interested in communicating anymore
and that's one of the very interesting
philosophical questions in fact we have
an institute down at Moffett Field
called the singularity University that's
starting to look at at these kind of
questions so I personally believe
probably there was intelligence he is
elsewhere and it very quickly passed
through the phase wherein and is
something else yeah that's interesting
I've had exactly the same time because
it's always you know search for life as
we know it right some and so ok we can
look down we don't see life as we know
it can we imagine life as we don't know
it
existing having existing and it's so not
how not as we know it that we can't even
see it it could be there and we can't
even see it if the word alien probably
doesn't begin to describe what is likely
out there and it's also a possibility
that we are the first which is a equally
interesting and scary concept that that
life is rare and that for some random
reason it happened here and it gets very
quickly into metaphysics and religion
which is really fun which is really
which is really fun and aren't there's
this physical like speed of light you
can only travel so far so fast before
human beings disintegrate
something like that allegedly allegedly
the I mean our understanding of physics
today says there are fundamental limits
to I mean the limit is the speed of
light you can only asymptotically
approach that still means you could go
pretty far in the in the in the universe
but it suggests that that an expanding
civilization at best would expand at the
speed of light now there's some very
interesting ideas that you know the
people in the fringe of physics say well
maybe you could there's ways around it
there's in fact if you watch science
fiction there's a lots of interesting
ways weird physics in an interesting way
I think science fiction is kind of a
blending of art and science right take a
little bit of science I move to a
creative place science fiction is what
gets all got all of us excited I mean I
write how many times I get science
fiction books taken away from me in
school you know I'm supposed to be
reading the text right okay I guess our
time is that we still got 24 seconds
well they you know come and talk to us
about what you think arc we ought to
take with us okay that's the fundamental
question that you know as we go we need
art maybe more than we need this ions
yeah and I would say in my quick answer
is take our tests that's that's what I
would be advocating for thank you thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you